hello my name is lisa i work for eu  humanitarian aid and civil protection i  am here at one of many warehouses in  poland where assistance that has been  sent through the eu civil protection  mechanism from various countries all  over europe actually all over the world  arrives and is being unloaded and put on  different trucks that are heading for  ukraine so it's been dispatched to make  sure that the materials actually go  where they're most needed what we see  arriving here at the moment is for  example medical supplies  we've seen medicines  there are tents arriving to poland  generators  behind me now is the truck that has just  arrived it is being unloaded this is  assistance coming from belgium  you